hello and welcome to the bank of
England's monetary policy report press
conference uh good to see you all uh to
my far right we have Ben draw Ben Deputy
Governor for monetary policy to my left
we have Dave ramsden Deputy Governor for
markets Banking and resolution and to my
immediate right the governor Andrew baby
Andrew will now open with some remarks
well thanks Seb and welcome to the
November monthly policy report press
conference
today we've increased bank rate by 0.75
percentage points to three percent
this is the eighth consecutive increase
in bank rate since December of last year
we've raised rates by a total of 2.9
percentage points during that period
these are big changes
they have a real impact on people's
lives
so why are we doing it and why are we
doing it now when so many people are
already struggling with higher energy
and food prices and other bills
well quite simply we're increasing bank
rate because inflation is too high
and it's the bank's job to bring it down
for a long time inflation have been low
and stable
most people did not have to worry about
inflation but that has changed
it's changed with supply chain problems
after the pandemic
the Russian invasion of Ukraine and the
shrinkage of the UK labor force
Consumer Price inflation now stands at
over 10 percent
but I know for many people it will feel
worse because the prices of Essentials
like energy and groceries have risen by
much more
to worry about inflation as they go
about their daily business
that's why we've been raising interest
rates and did so again today
low and stable inflation is the Bedrock
of a stable economy
a predictable economy in which people
can go about their lives and plan for
their future with confidence
an economy in which hard-earned money
keeps its value
if we do not act forcefully now it will
be worse later on
and as the forecast we are publishing
today shows
it is a tough road ahead
the sharp increase in Energy prices
caused by Russia's invasion of Ukraine
has made us poorer as a nation
the level of economic activity is likely
to be flat and even fall for some time
but the economy will recover and
inflation will fall
we cannot have afraid pretend to know
what will happen to gas prices that
depends on the war in in Ukraine
but from where we stand now we think
inflation will begin to fall back from
the middle of next year
probably quite sharply
now to make sure that happens bank rate
may have to go up further over the
coming months
we can't make promises about future
interest rates
but based on where we stand today
we think bank rate will have to go up by
less than currently priced in financial
markets
and that's important
because for instance it means that the
rates on new fixed term mortgages should
not need to rise as they have done
I want to make some additional points
and there will be some slides coming up
I believe
there we are
to start with there have been
significant volatility in UK financial
markets since our last monetary policy
reporting indeed our last press
conference back at the beginning of
August
so the lines in this chart show you the
peak level of interest rates expected in
financial markets and various economies
and how those expectations have moved
around since our last forecast
the expectations of Bankrate here in the
UK are plotted on the turquoise line
at the time of the August report the
market implied path for bank rate Rose
to a peak of about three percent in
March next year
by the NPC's September policy
announcement which was on the 22nd of
September the peak was five percent one
year ahead
on the 27th of September five days later
when turmoil in the market was most
intense the path reached its highest
peak
that nearly six and a half percent in
November next year
at the market closed yesterday it stood
at about four and three quarter percent
and it's currently lower than that now
given these moves we have conditioned
our November forecast on an average of
the market implied paths over the final
seven days of our usual 15-day window
this means that the forecast we present
today is conditioned on a path of bank
rate that rises to a peak of five and a
quarter percent
during the second quarter of next year
now despite the shorter window this is
substantially higher than we had in
August
part of this repricing in UK interest
rates reflects Global developments
but as this next chart illustrates has
clearly been a UK specific component you
can see that in the light turquoise bars
indeed these significant moves in UK
yields and in UK Financial conditions
more broadly have occurred in parallel
with significant developments in fiscal
policy
as we describe in a box in the military
policy report the government has
announced an energy price guarantee and
an energy bill relief scheme
these schemes Provide support to
households and businesses with their
energy bills
now the full energy price guarantee will
now last for six months
details are yet to follow on the level
of support provided beyond that period
the NPC is therefore adopted a stylized
indicative path for household Energy
prices and producing the forecast
the working assumption is that the
typical household Energy bill is halfway
between the announced 2 500 pound limit
under the EPG
and the level implied by Futures prices
under the off-chem price cap
the energy support policies are likely
to limit significantly further increases
in inflation and reduce its volatility
while also supporting spending relative
to the August projections
other physical measures announced as of
the 17th of October also support demand
relative to the August projection
but the the November forecast does not
incorporate any fiscal measures that may
be announced at the Autumn statement
scheduled for the 17th of November
turning to gas prices sadly as a
consequence of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine
I've had to talk at length about
wholesale gas prices which is the third
press conference we've had to do this
wholesale gas prices continue to be
exceptionally volatile
spot prices have fallen recently as you
can see from the turquoise line in this
chart
but medium-term Futures prices have been
driven Higher by Russia's restriction of
gas supplies to Europe
and concerns about storage over the
winter
and Beyond
now you can see that by comparing the
orange line for November with the purple
line for August
the committee has conditioned its
November forecast on the full Futures
curve for wholesale energy and
non-energy commodity prices and this is
a change to the previous convention that
wholesale Energy prices follow their
respective curves for the first six
months of the projection only and then
remain constant
uh to be frank I would just describe
this as a pragmatic choice we had to
make the new conditioning assumption
avoids what would otherwise be a purely
purely mechanical jump in the projection
for Consumer prices which will be a
product of using the former convention
beyond the assumed two-year duration of
the government's support to Retail
Energy prices
let me move on to the economic Outlook
by comparison with moves in financial
markets the news in the economic data
since August has been more modest
gross domestic product has been weaker
than we expected
labor market data have been stronger
and inflation numbers while high have
come in about as we expected in August
we keep a close eye on the labor market
there are some signs that labor demand
is starting to soften
but the labor market remains tight
the unemployment rate fell to 3.5
percent of the three months to August
which is the lowest level since 1974.
as you can see in the next in this next
chart in the purple bars the number of
unemployed people has now fallen below
its pre-covert level
but a key reason why the labor market
has tightened since the pandemic is a
marked increase in the number of people
who are without a job and who are not
actively seeking one
the number of such so-called inactive
people has risen again since the August
report as you can see in the blue bars
and by more than projected
and sadly many of the people who are
outside the labor market report that
they suffer from long-term sickness
to say a little bit about the forecast
and looking further forwards
the MPC expects domestic inflationary
pressures to remain strong over the next
year
but in its Central production projection
which is conditioned on the market
implied path for Bank rates that rises
to five and a quarter percent inflation
then Falls sharply
it reaches 1.4 percent at the end of the
second year below the two percent Target
and it falls to zero at the end of the
third year
contributing to this fall is the purely
arithmetic fact that the previous rises
in Energy prices drop out of the
calculations of the annual inflation
rate
but in addition tighter Financial
conditions and a squeeze on real income
slow demand and eventually lead to
excess Supply and Rising unemployment
this downturn in the economy dampens
domestic inflationary pressures
in the committee's best Collective
judgment GDP will continue to fall
throughout next year and into 2024.
compared with previous UK recessions GDP
remains weak relative to its
pre-recession level for a prolonged
period
you can see that in the yellow line in
this chart
there is I think however more to this
story the committee will not pursue a
path that we think will drive inflation
far below Target
the MPC does not follow the market it
sets the level of Bank rates return
inflation to the two percent Target
sustainably
and in a way that avoids under desirable
volatility and output
in every monetary policy report we also
publish a projection condition on a
constant level of bank rate
though for the avoidance of any doubt
with the clear warning that it does not
mean the committee expects to keep bank
rate constant either
but that said comparing outcomes under
this alternative conditioning assumption
with outcomes in the central projection
gives a sense of how different policy
decisions May shape the paths for
economic activity and inflation
and you can see that with this chart now
with the dashed yellow line that's been
added which is conditioned on a constant
level of bank rate at three percent
and you can see that the depth of the
recession is much shallower
not surprisingly the projected outcomes
for inflation are also different
condition on a constant rate Consumer
Price inflation is projected to be a
little above rather than below the
target at the end of the second year
and let me add a further point before I
conclude
regardless of the path for bank rate the
MPC judges that the risk to its
inflation projections are skewed to the
upside
in part the ski reflects the possibility
of more persistence in wage and price
setting
the episode skew has important
implications for monetary policy
just to put it simply yes we project a
steep form of inflation but there are
substantial upside risks to that path
and it's not least for this reason the
majority of the committee judges that
further increases in Bank rates may be
required to return inflation sustainably
to Target should the economy evolve
broadly in line with the forecast
presented in the November martial policy
report
however the central projections
conditional on the market implied power
for bank rate
serve as a reminder that we should not
increase bank rate too far
the NPC judges that the path for bank
rate required to return inflation
sustainably to Target is shallower than
that priced into financial markets
there are however considerable
uncertainties around the Outlook
if the Outlook suggests more persistent
inflation pressures the committee will
respond forcefully as necessary
and with that Ben Dave and I will be
happy to take your questions thank you
thanks Andrew
um with questions usual process grateful
if you could wait for the microphones to
get to you and state your name and
organization clearly when you start I'll
get through as many as I can and with
that Faisal then Ed to start
foreign
[Music]
when they're facing three thousand pound
energy bills Rising taxes to
can you how can you justify that they're
going to be paying the price for this
well it's another good question for
instance I want to start by saying that
we do understand the difficulties of the
situation we're in and the difficulties
you know the the mortgage holders face
what I would say however is I would say
two things first of all
if we don't take action to bring
inflation down it gets worse I've never
said this before but I will say it again
there is no easy outcome to this in that
sense and that's important
the second thing I want to say and of
course this applies to people who will
be applying for mortgages or will be
you know rolling over uh fixed rate
mortgages
there's been a lot of commentary and
quite rightly about what has happened to
the mortgage Market in the last month or
so
but what's happened to rates and to
availability of mortgages
my Central View would be that what we
have announced today both in terms of
the rate move which is fully priced it
was was fully priced into markets
and the message that you'll have seen
that we've given I think very clearly
about our view on the market curve
is that therefore this action should not
lead to higher mortgage rates in fact
actually I think you know there is a
yeah there is a downside to mortgage
rates in that sense in terms of new
fixed rate mortgages as we adjust
as we must do and as markets are doing
from the experiences we've had in the
last month or so
now I fully accept that as more Comfort
to some people than others and I want to
go back to the points I made to start
which you rightly highlight this is a
difficult time
quite a lot has happened since the last
time you sat here for for one of these
press conferences we've had three prime
ministers three chancellors more u-turns
than anyone can care to count do you
have a sense of how much lasting damage
has been done to the economy
in the last two months for households or
businesses for everyone
well I think I
I think you have to sort of put a number
of sort of lenses on that it's a very
good question so
as as we've observed
yeah and I think the first chart showed
it very well actually that I mean there
has been what I would call it a UK
premium on rates so if you look at how
UK rates have moved since we were here
at the beginning of August compared to
the euro area and compared to the U.S
which that chart did you'll see they've
all gone up but the UK clearly you know
clearly went up far far more and it went
up during this period when there was of
course a considerable turmoil in the
markets now the first thing I would say
an important thing is that we are seeing
that unwind now I mean that is
substantially Unwound we're
substantially back to certainly where we
were when we had our last meeting in in
September which was just before that
um and that's obviously a good thing
Market liquidity that I think Dave may
want to come in is not back to where
where we were
the third thing is and I think this is
you know this is an issue that we have
to face up to I was very acutely aware
of it when we were in you know we were
in Washington recently is that you know
there is
yeah there has been a questioning of UK
policy they're using UK policy broadly
here it's not for me to talk about but
I'm not going to talk about politics I'm
just going to talk about policy now
um and that will have some lasting
effect and we have to work very hard to
you know to to put that in the past
frankly
you want to say about Market liquidity
though
all I would add is we have seen that
round tripping uh back to where rates
were on the 22nd of
September that was the day of our last
monetary policy
a meeting was the day before the
government's mini budget
um and so you've seen the you know for
example the two-year ois uh sorry
two-year swap rate which is what
two-year fixed rate mortgages are priced
off that was 4.5 on the 22nd of
September it peaked at six percent it's
actually come back to slightly below 4.5
now it's at
4.38 as of
um a few minutes ago that obviously
hasn't fed through into mortgage
mortgage pricing yet which was the Point
Andrew was was just alluding to but
although we're seeing those kind of
round trips whether they're or in the
10-year bond yield it's clear that
markets remain febrile there's
illiquidity across uh different parts of
the market so I think things have not
settled down yet and and that's
obviously something that we're very
focused on in terms of monitoring market
conditions
and then Chris
Joanna Versace from CNBC
um the Fed chair Jerome Powell yesterday
suggested that the bigger risk was one
of under tightening versus over
tightening I just wonder if you have the
same view as well given even with a
three percent constant interest rates
you you have an inflation forecast of
0.8 percentage points three years out
and eighth consecutive quarters actually
no with the three percent it's six
consecutive quarters of a negative GDP
thank you
well I'll bring better at this point I
mean I think there are things that we
share
in terms of our experience and
assessment with the fed and then there
are very important differences between
what certainly certainly in the UK but
actually I'd say more Europe more
generally are experiencing in terms of
shocks from what the US is experiencing
and I you know I do think in the
commentary and in the discussions it's
important to draw out those distinctions
as well so Ben did you want to yeah
excuse me on that three-year forecast
if you remember gas prices have fallen
quite a lot so it doesn't give you
uh the straightest picture of sort of
underlying inflation
um on that constant rate assumption
but as Andrew says there's a big big
difference between what's gone on both
with inflation and growth
between us and Europe
um
and as Andrew says it's not always that
made that clear
so the pandemic was a common shock to
all of us the war is not
the gas prices have gone up hugely in
Europe not much at all the United States
there's still barely 10 percent
in the United States wholesale gas
prices compared with those in Europe
just as a measure of the difference in
growth I just wrote down before I came
up the the
PMI indices which are good high
frequency and up-to-date measure of
growth
at the beginning of the year and what
they are now at the beginning of the
year they were
all of them in the UK us and Europe very
healthy above Trend coming out of the
pandemic so 54 of the Euro area 57 in
the U.S 58 in the UK
right the latest readings of 58 in the
United States that's higher than it was
just before the war
and they're down at 47 in the UK and
Europe we've got a really really big
difference between the path of growth
here and by here I mean in the continent
of Europe
versus United States
you see similar differences now in the
composition of inflation
and I think that explains quite a lot of
you know what Divergence there is in
policy but also for example a part of
the strength of the dollar against both
the UK and Europe
and it's a big difference you know
pandemic as I say was a shock felt by
everybody this one is very
differentiated
Chris
Giles on the financial times if I'd like
to ask a question about the
interpretation of the forecast on two
grounds if I may
um the inflation forecast is closer to
your Target on the constant three
percent rate assumption than the market
path going up to five and a quarter
percent so our would people be correct
in assuming that was closer to where you
think the terminal rate should be
somewhere close to where it is today
than going up and secondly the forecast
is conditioned on fiscal policy not
changing on November the 17th when the
treasury is suggesting a large fiscal
tightening of maybe up to two percent of
GDP how would that change the inflation
forecast
well I'll start I mean so sort of Ben
David I want to come in I mean I'll do a
reverse order if you don't mind Chris I
mean I think the answer to answer your
second question of course is that we
will uh we always we always condition on
announced fiscal policy now as I
explained in the introductory marks
we've had to sort of think quite hard
about in the context of the energy side
what the word announced means and but
what I think is a sort of stylized but
sensible interpretation on it but
um on the other measures which as I said
quite explicitly they do not appear in
the forecast we will of course take
those into account uh when we next meet
and then in our next forecast as we
always would do and we'll see what the
chancellor announces I think my answer
is a really really interesting question
on the on your first part to your
question is
the last chart we put I put out when we
put up which had the sort of you you
could see the difference between the two
the two parts if you like in GDP terms
um and you rightly say you could you can
you can use a similar inflation chart
um I would just emphasize the points
that there is an upside risk on
inflation
and it actually is an MPC history it's a
it's one maybe the largest actually
upside risk uh in MPC in NPC history and
that reflects certainly the labor market
you know obviously the issues around
around gas prices sadly as well
so we're not we're very clearly not
saying you know we're not putting our
sort of you know our bet either way in
terms of which is the better curve but
it's important that since we do think
the market curve is too high that I
think it's useful as a sort of guideline
to show and show where the alternative
is but where you know obviously where
the truthful line between the two it's
we're not giving guidance on that
because we don't predict the market bars
precisely Dave if you want to just to
add to what Andrew said so we've got
this historically large skew on the
inflation fan chart which is our way of
quantifying that upside risk on
inflation and I think you know that
reflects the factors that we've been
focusing on more and more through this
year which is concerns around
Persistence of inflation from
domestically generated inflation that
could be because of
um the tightness of the labor market but
equally also from firms
looking at environment where they think
they can put up prices and those kind of
inflation drivers carry with them the
risk of being more persistent
hence you know the the communication
that we gave that the majority of us
assuming that projections broadly follow
the the numbers that we've just polished
published think that we'll have to make
further increases in bank rate to get
inflation sustainably back to Target and
to your other point I wouldn't be
thinking in terms of
you know looking at those two constant
rate or current rate paths uh to work
out where we think the the neutral uh
rate is that's not something we are
focusing on what we are focusing on is
where we think interest rates have to go
in the meantime that's the focus and
that's of our Communications
just one tiny thing obviously
the fiscal announcement coming what
matters for us is the effects of fiscal
policy in our forecast Horizon
and the government's planning Horizon
may be slightly longer than that
a kind of a new city and then Ashley
please
Lucy white from the daily mail um
Governor you said in your opening
remarks um
you know fixed home mortgages should not
need to rise as they have done um you've
addressed that
um what would you say to the lenders who
have been you know putting their rates
up in um in recent weeks and what would
you say you know in terms of responsible
lending for the future and what would
you say
um to you know the consumers who have
had to lock in over the last few weeks
either you know because they thought the
picture was going to get worse or
because you know it just it was the time
well it's a good question
um well I start by saying that because
the mortgage Market in this country over
the last decade or so has moved quite
substantially from being a variable rate
Market to a fixed rate Market not of
course fixed rates in the sense that the
US knows in terms of duration but
nonetheless
uh much more of a fixed rate Market than
a variable rate market now fixed
mortgage rates are priced off the market
curve because of the swap because
there's a swap there's a swap involved
in there for the lending institution uh
so that whereas variable rate mortgages
traditionally have priced far more off
off our rate if you like and as it moves
fixed rate mortgages have priced far
more off the market curve now that the
reason I say that that's important of
course is that as we saw and if we've
Illustrated and said as we saw this real
you know blowout blow up of uh of the
market curve as it happened
um that obviously had an impact on
pricing mortgages
um
I think it also Dave was making this
point as well it also made uh lenders
you know pretty uncertain of course
about what about what they were facing
in terms of making offers which would
last for however long and I think that
explains two things that you point to
one is the the increase in in new fixed
mortgage rates and secondly the
withdrawal of offers from the market now
it follows I hope I would I would
suggest from what we've said that that
is now calm it's calming down the curve
is coming down so pricing off the curve
you know is getting more predictable I
think uh and the curve itself is is
coming down and that should be reflected
through as many commentators and I know
quite a few of you have said in you know
what you've written in recent days and
in the last week or so that should be
reflected through into mortgage rates I
mean that's yeah these things have to be
symmetric in that sense so that's that
would be my you know my view of How It's
evolved I'm not going to give
predictions of precise mortgage rates
that's not not something I think that's
our job but but I would expect that that
pattern to be reflected through and so
therefore I think people who are you
know now in the process of going for new
fixed rate mortgages or rolling over
should obviously get uh get those terms
I I to your point though of course it is
I think it is very unfortunate that
those who've had to
had to take mortgages out during this
period have faced a much more difficult
uh situation
and if I I mean just the facts of that
we will be publishing numbers tomorrow
that we cover in the in the minutes
but the quoted rate on a two-year fixed
rate 75 loan to value mortgage
um
six percent in October which is its
highest since 2008 whereas it was 3.6 in
August 4.2 in September so it's clearly
you know the spread on mortgages which
was quite compressed has opened up a lot
and there is a lag so it will take time
for mortgage pricing to reflect that but
yeah we will we will wait to see how
mortgage pricing does reflect the fact
that the reference the reference rates
that I was giving you earlier have come
down a lot from those equivalent Peaks I
mean what was striking was that the
pricing the pass-through was very quick
on the way up so it gets back to
Andrew's point about you know looking to
see how quick it is on the way down
Ashley
the sun two if I may you mentioned the
UK premium it has been called reader
things but let's call it the mini budget
premium as well I mean how much would
you think that interest rates and
inflation
sorry interest rates would have to rise
if there hadn't been this instability in
the guilt Market that we saw and
um
and and kind of That Knocking effect
like how much is that having an impact
on this and the second point would be
given that we are going to go through
what you're predicting a two-year long
recession the longest since we've had
since 1920s
do you not think that
adding to the household pain of adding
interest rates at that time you're
already seeing that the economy is
slowing we're already seeing these
indicators why should we be kind of
having that higher interest rates during
this painful period as well
let me start I it really isn't possible
to do what I call a sort of
counterfactual interest rate
counter-factual NPC decision what would
we have decided had none of the sort of
the events of the last sort of couple of
months actually happened
um I mean I you know I did say earlier
that
you know there has been relatively much
less economic news but I mean this but
the I would however emphasize the the
components of the sort of the of the
risk that we the upside risk that we see
to inflation uh towards the end of the
forecast are really related to the labor
markets uh
uh so sadly some of it too I suspect gas
prices as well and those things are not
of course to do with uh to do with
what's happened in the last few months
so so I you know I I would sort of
really only draw those points out it's
not possible for us to do when I sort of
say counterfactual NPC in that sense on
your points about the recession
um
really go back to having a good point in
time I made to Faisal um in his question
which is
the fact of the matter is that if we
don't tackle the inflation then the
problem gets worse
um and that would that would rebound
onto frankly the both the duration and
the nature of the recession I think
one thing a word of caution on the
duration if you look at the for what
it's worth the central
projection that the quarterly numbers as
you get into the second year of
but don't they're very small
right and in particular they're very
small compared with the kind of standard
error around this it really wouldn't
take much either to lengthen or shorten
that duration considerably the important
thing for us is
what is likely to be the increase in
spare capacity required to ensure that
domestic inflation returns sustainably
to Target
and after allowing
for the negative effects on demand of
the very same shocks that have pushed up
inflation energy pandemic and so forth
how much more is the left for us to do
and it's it's in the nature
of the extraordinary sequence of
difficult shocks the economy has faced
that at the same time it's pushed up
inflation and yet depressed growth and
unfortunately I mean it's very important
that we do our job and make sure that
that inflation does not persist for
longer than it should
but as far as the duration as I say the
projected duration is concerned
I wouldn't be that confident about the
precise number of quarters frankly given
the shape of what we're forecasting it's
quite flat as you get to the end of the
downturn
Larry them zoo please
the guardian
um
the bank is saying that we're about to
have a two-year recession two members of
the committee didn't vote for a 75 point
increase you're saying that on constant
rate assumptions inflation would be
quite close to its Target in two years
time and I know you're not saying where
you think rates are going to Peak but
couldn't people be forgiven for thinking
that rates are going to Peak closer to
three percent than the 4.6 percent
currently being anticipated by the
markets isn't that the message that
you're actually trying to send out here
well I mean by the way I mean I think
you were saying this Larry but just just
to be absolutely clear of course the
constant rate assumption is is post the
increase is it's a three percent
constant rate in that sense just to be
clear
I mean
you'll probably criticize me for stating
the blindingly obvious at this point but
I mean in a sense what we're saying we
are saying is that you know our sort of
you know our best uh view of what the
rate should be given the situation
circumstances and the evidence we have
to dates
is uh is is nearer to the constant rate
curve than the market curve is to the
constant rate curve currently now that's
as you say thank you for that statement
to the Blind and the obvious I think
you'll probably say at this point
um but just to reiterate I mean we do
not have a you know a precise
alternative path because you know the
reason I have to somewhat labor in my
opening remarks the conditioning
assumptions is that we've made more
changes to the conditioning assumption
this time out of necessity than probably
we ever have before actually because
things have happened
um but those conditioning assumptions
are of course an important part of
determining sort of the outcome in terms
of where the forecast takes you to we
can then apply sort of our judgment over
that which we have done but our judgment
doesn't it doesn't lead us to a precise
number in that sense
can I just be clear on another factual
point which is that the conditioning
path for the market rate for base
forecast
has was an ois curve with the peak in
bank rate five and a quarter so not not
the current level of bank rate it's the
yeah the seven days was implied a peak
bank rate of five and a quarter yeah we
have to cut off so that we can actually
produce the reports yeah and it's a it's
a sign of the times that the curve has
moved quite a bit since we actually cut
off
let's see
just to follow on from what you guys
have just said why have you decided so
explicitly to push back against those
market rate expectations and I know you
just said um that inflation risks
remains skewed to the Ops
and more you know
well Ben developed this thought in his
speech the other day so I'm going to let
Ben develop it some more
um
if there is
I mean I guess I hope it's reasonably
clear in the minutes we think that it's
likely given this forecast that further
rate Rises will be necessary
but if you think of that comparison that
Andrew began with between what the
market was expecting at the time of the
August report without commenting on
whether either is precisely right or
wrong but the scale of the move in the
predicted Peak over the following two
months was enormous
so it's perfectly possible
and this is where we are to say we think
further Rises will be
likely to have to occur
but we also think they're not likely to
have to go as high as five and a quarter
percent given everything else in the
forecast I mean both those statements
are true
and
the point about forceful is varying more
towards a conditional statement that's
very important that we always make that
what actually happens will depend on the
shocks that actually hit the economy and
the thing to take away I think is not so
much that we we had some predict you
know particular value of interest rates
that we're telling people we're going to
go to we will do whatever is necessary
to ensure that our projections of medium
to inflation are close sustainably close
to Target
and this on this particular forecast
it suggests that a we don't think it
wouldn't be if the things turned out
like the forecast necessary to go to
phone recorder but yes further rate
risers are likely to be necessary
both those things are true
[Music]
thanks Phil aldrick at Bloomberg can I
just get a point clarified to begin with
because you talk about the correct path
of Ray roses doesn't need to be what has
been priced into financial markets
you've you mentioned 5.25 Peak and you
mentioned 4.75 peak in the in the
documents in in different places so are
both of those Market paths too high or
are you being specific about a single
one so just a point of clarity
um and what in this newfound Spirit of
clarification
um of collaboration between uh fiscal
and monetary policy I'm just wondering
if you've got any ideas about what
measures might help the bank hit its
inflation targets more fiscal tightening
and particularly with uh with regard to
the um uh job shortages if there's
anything that could ease job shortages
just those kind of policy measures well
well I'll do the second up Dave may want
to do the first I think I'll do the same
I mean sort of a nice try to get me to
sort of lecture the government on what
his policy should be but it really is
for the government
um I mean I you know I think our you
know our report lays out the situation
it lays out the the issues that the
economy faces you're right and it's what
I made the point that I think in in
everything that's been going on recently
we should not get away from the fact
that there's a real issue in terms of
the size of the labor force in this
country which has shrunk
but it's not for me to prescribe what
government probably even suggests What
government policy should be
just on
just to set out as as as clearly as as
we can I mean I think it is set out in
Paris 16 of the minute the NPC's
projections were conditioned on the path
of bank rate implied by financial
markets in the seven working days
leading up to 25th of October that that
path was rising to a peak of five and a
quarter percent in 2023 Q3 so all the
forecast numbers based on the market
path that's where the five and a quarter
comes from we then just report that in
and this goes to my point that markets
remain febrile even these pretty liquid
markets that in the run-up to our
November decision yesterday the peak had
come down to four and three quarter but
the conditioning path is the five and a
quarter
thanks
hi uh Marine from the times just on on
what happened today given that inflation
is still in line with your August
forecast the fact that we've had a
financial tightening and that we can
expect uh fiscal consolidation is the
reason that you opted for 75 today
because it was priced in by the market
and not delivering that would have
produced maybe more volatility than you
would have liked in this febrile
environment and as if I'd say that we're
not going to be seeing 75 moving forward
and another question the FED yesterday
stressed that it is now thinking about
the cumulative impact that its rate
Rises are having
um on inflation are you also going to be
start thinking about all of the action
you've done so far and the sort of
variable lag that's now going to have on
the economy and inflation going forward
I I was trying to say the answer there's
a no and yes no in the sense that we we
do not
um follow the market
um you know we obviously condition on
the market half of the forecast but I
would draw a distinction between the
forecast and our judgment on the policy
decision and you can see that from
obviously from the way we've described
our you know our thinking on that and
our thinking on the uh that the forecast
path condition by the market so no we
don't uh you know we don't follow the
market and you know we are prepared as
you can probably you can probably
recount from the past there are times
when we're prepared to you know to
diverge from the market path and accept
that that would obviously lead to some
repricing so
um you know I think that's that's that's
a very important one did you want to
come with us well only to be very clear
because I hope it's clear in the minute
what led to this decision now
embarrassing we're always looking at all
the data we saw upside surprises in
wages and inactivity and that's been a
key area of focus for the second round
effects of higher food and energy and
other imported goods process
that's been important for a while and we
saw another upside surprise in that
and we don't know yet what's going to
happen with fiscal policy and in
particular following Chris's question
fiscal policy in the relatively near
term which is what affects our forecast
what we do know is that the energy price
package will be a significant support to
demand relative to the August forecast
forecast
and each of those two things justifies
tighter policy
and we are always LED taking account of
what we've already done
to link it to your second question to
think about what is the right level of
interest rates and the right path to hit
the inflation Target we do not just
simply reflect back what the market
already thinks I mean it's their job to
follow us not asked to follow that
and just on this point about do we take
account of what's already happened I
mean as Andrew set out in his opening
remarks we've been this is the eighth
consecutive meeting that we've put up
rates so every meeting since December
2021
when rates were at point one we've been
raising rates by cumulative now 2.9 and
we are very conscious of that that
cumulative impact is feeding through
onto the economy and is is adding to the
challenges that households and
businesses are facing so I think we've
been pretty consistent in flagging that
cumulative effect
on your second question I just emphasize
that point because one of the things
obviously we do spend quite a lot of
time on is the transmission of monetary
policies so how each of our decisions
transmits into uh into outcomes and
um yeah we are obviously as we approach
the anniversary of the of the first
interest rate rise and given what we
know about the transmission mechanism
yes of course that the impact of the
transmission of our earlier decisions is
is obviously a factor in our
consideration
um and of course we also by the way have
to consider going back to the question
on mortgages of course we also have to
consider how the transmission mechanism
changes and adapts over time as aspects
of the economy and the aspects of the of
the financial system change
thank you
given the lag in monetary policy when do
you expect today's rate to be felt
um on your on your inflation you know
inflation in the country like when will
people expect to experience that are you
waiting to see evidence of inflation
going down in domestic price pressures
as well as those global factors before
you think about slowing down or even
ending this current hiking cycle
that's a very good question
um
you know we're focused as always I mean
one of the reasons we use the forecast
both to think about policy and describe
it
is because whereas because of the lags
that you discuss
and I'm not trying to
suggest that there are very precise
estimates but typically you might expect
a peak effect of an interest rate change
on demand
you know a year or maybe a little bit
less
and inflation say 18 to 24 months or
maybe maybe longer than that under some
circumstances
so it's because of those lags indeed
that we have a forecast in the first
place
what will determine how long this goes
on for or should be seen much more in
the context of that forecast which
depends on lots of things and lots of
indicators rather than any single one we
had stressed the domestic labor market
as one key indicator of domestic
inflationary pressure
um but I wouldn't want to pick up one
single indicator even within that
frankly
but it's more as I say to do with our
assessment of medium-term inflation
there are lots of things that go into
that forecast rather than the current
rate of inflation
and precisely because of the lags you
talk about and I'm not going to say that
means you know that interest rates will
either stop going up at this particular
point or Peak at this particular level
we don't know yet
but it's a slightly broader framing
that we consider rather than any
specific indicator
um Jack Bonnet from the city am
um on both of these projections you've
got on the co um the constant rate and
the market rate I mean they're pretty
bleak on both sides I mean are you
essentially saying that this part of the
so-called soft Landing is now kind of
dead
um you know we're not going to avoid
this recession we actually might even
need this recession to push down
inflation to complement Rising
um bank rate and then just secondly you
obviously mentioned there that we're
approaching
um the year anniversary when we first
raise interest rates just kind of
staking taking a step back from maybe
all of you I mean how how sharp is the
swing been in the economy's performance
when we were going into that meeting to
now
excuse me
well let me start by saying um
I think
when we look at the path of the
recession
it's worth bearing in mind always the
sheer size of the of the shock that we
have experienced to real income in this
country
call it terms of trade shock if you like
from events and particularly obviously
during the course of this year from
events surrounding Russia's invasion of
Ukraine I mean this is a huge shock
you know it's so interesting I think Ben
has said in the past that if you compare
this to the 1970s
when you compared this year to single
years in the 1970s
and obviously government policies also
come into play there in terms of energy
markets
this is a bigger shock than we saw in a
year in the 1970s so
what I don't for a moment want to sort
of ring my hands and say a recession is
inevitable when you look at those paths
you have to look at them in the context
of the shock that the economy is
experiencing and sadly of course the
people of this country are experiencing
so I would put it into that context we
were never I mean you said we're now not
saying it's a soft Landing we were
forecasting recession in August if you
remember this is not the first time
we're forecast a recession
and as Andrew emphasizes the different I
mean soft Landing is often used to
describe the aims of policy time in the
United States and I emphasize the
question answer the question I gave it
we're in a very very different position
because on its own the rises in import
prices of goods food of energy will
depress growth here
we then have to decide relatively how
much more do we have to do
to ensure that the combined pressure of
those real income hits and uh monetary
tightening bring inflation back to
Target but I didn't think we've ever
said we're aiming for a soft lab we're
aiming to bring inflation back to Target
that's what we're aiming to do
and it's been a feature of the forecast
for a long time because of the nature of
this shock
the growth of forecast for growth have
got progressively weaker and as I say we
had a forecast procession
in August and you ask about the
turnaround this time last year before
Energy prices really started Rising
the forecast had the central Focus I
think was for GDP growth for The
Following over the following year so to
the fourth quarter of this year of
almost three percent and it's now 0.2
that's already happened that's that's a
measure of the scale not so much of the
tightening and interest rates because of
those lags
but the the direct effect of the huge
rise and import prices particularly the
energy
it's also obviously I want to say so
it's interesting just to recall a year
you know this time a year ago when we
were sitting here a year ago and the
issue we were wrestling with and it was
remember the decision we're talking
about meeting was you know it was
attracted a lot of commentary let me put
it that way but the issue we were
wrestling with then was the really in my
view was the labor market and if what
what was the impact at the end of the
furlough scheme on the labor market and
yeah that's and it remains an important
issue in in the sense that the labor
market remains important and the whole
question of the tightness of the labor
market remains important
uh and I think we like other forecasters
were you know were you know surprised
I'll say this that the ending of the
photo scheme didn't lead to any
loosening of the labor market any any
really marked and certainly prolonged
rise in unemployment
but I say it also because just to recall
him and it is interesting to put into
context just how many major events have
happened in the intervening period I
mean it is
you know it is it's pretty striking here
we go back to a year ago what you know
what what the issues were a year ago and
then everything that has happened
subsequently
Francine
Francine like what Bloomberg TV um
Governor now that you've started QT do
you have any estimates on how much
tightening that will impart
IAL
on QT now that you started QT how much
tightening does that impact
resident QT expert
um I will I'll differentiate the answer
from the the one I gave
uh previously I mean we we've always
thought of QT as being very different
from QE in the sense that when we were
doing QE we were trying to send a signal
about what was going to happen to bank
rate that's clearly not the case with QT
and also we quite often did QE at times
when markets were were really not
functioning well and that those episodes
tended to be when Q QE had its most
significant effect which is why we talk
about QE being State contingent QT is
also State contingent but we've made
clear the NPC has made clear that it
would not do
QT under
um issues of Market dysfunction we were
we did Port we did pause the start of
our active guilt sales by a few weeks
because of what we were seeing
particularly at the long end uh of the
Government Bond Market back at the end
of September so we paused from we were
planning to start in early October we
didn't start until Tuesday when we did
our first auction and carried that off
successfully
um
750 million proceeds one of eight
auctions we're going to do uh in the
remainder of this year
um a total of around 6 billion and and I
guess the final point I'd make is we
throughout our the way we've planned our
QT program going back to last August
we've tried to be deliberate we've tried
to be we've always said that we would do
this in as predictable way as possible
and that means it should be priced into
markets as and when we do it so it's
impossible to extract
you know what was the exact effect
either of the total program that the MPC
has set out which is 80 billion over a
year or of any particular auction
I mean just on the stake contingent
points that I think there is also
certainly in the current context another
piece of State contingency which is that
you know it's quite a few Market
contents we'll tell you a number of you
have written I know there is currently
quite a quite a wedge between the
unsecured rate and and secured so GC
collateral rates in the repo market and
that of course is relevant to to us
selling assets into the market in many
ways I mean people are saying to us as a
shortage of collateral in the Market at
the moment so in a state contingency
sense of the immediate context that's
that's relevant and actually to your
question Francine that would suggest
that you know our sales are not going to
have that much impact in that sense
cumulatively and indeed when we when we
published the revised plans for the
sales we deliberately skewed the sales
to the short and medium buckets so that
we can support the market by providing
collateral and equally given you know
still concerns potentially at the long
end we thought it was you know we can
start selling our from the longer end of
our Holdings in the new year
hi David Millican from Reuters um just
on a point of clarification I'm a sort
of Governor when you were sort of
talking about these sort of likely path
for rates being sort of likely to be
close to a constant path than a market
rate path were you talking about sort of
the market rate I didn't say that all
right what I said was
um that it would be it if you think
about the what the gap between the the
market path we have uh in the forecast
and the constant rate path I said the
you know our commentary would suggest
that the path would be nearer to the
constant rate path than the market uh
rate path in the forecast and you know
and I'll repeat the apology I made to
Larry that's a statement to the blind in
the obvious there's nothing
yeah there's nothing more than that it
amounts to saying simply that we thought
we wouldn't have to get as far as the
market yeah I've given the forecast
and sorry just to finish finish that
part so it was that sort of were you
talking about the sort of market rate
path as it was at the time of the sort
of forecasts when they were sent for the
market rate path as it is today
yeah and the market rate pass today is
lower I mean as I was saying earlier
that's an interesting sort of feature of
the times we live in that although not
that much time has a lap since we came
to the end of the window for the for the
forecast actually it's moved quite a bit
since then and it's moved downwards but
as I said we're not giving uh you know
we it's it's not we're not giving us
sort of you know here's our line that's
not what we do so I'm not going to
comment on sort of you know how much is
today's curve you know in the right
place relative to you know what it was a
week ago yeah we've done one the
statement is about
the market path at the time and
underlying at the time of an underlying
the forecast we've just published not
what it is minute by minute
and sort of more broadly do you feel the
sense that you're sort of Flying Blind a
little bit with still a huge amount of
sort of uncertainty about sort of
government fiscal policy what exactly is
going to be sort of coming up sort of
how much tightening we're likely to be
getting
back to what I said earlier
um
we moved you know we moved on from what
you might call the sort of the
long-established definition of announced
in terms of fiscal policy in terms of
the energy package because you know if
if I can sort of I think I can describe
what the chancellor has said
if you think about two bookends oh this
is what happens after April obviously
what happens to be now in April is is
set if you think about two bookends one
of which is uh that there is no package
of there is no household support after
April the other which is is that the
full package remains in place I think I
think it's clear that chancellor has
said that neither of those are things
that he intends to pursue so we're
obviously not be sensible for us to
condition on those two and therefore I
think it wasn't it was it was required
and natural that we had to make an
assumption that fell somewhere between
the two but it's a it's frankly it's a
stylized assumption it's not it's not in
any sense I say well we know what's
going to happen because we don't
actually in that sense
um and then on the rest of fiscal policy
we have followed our normal practice
that if it isn't announced it isn't in
there as it were so whatever else The
Chance is going to say at the fiscal
statement that's going to come up
um that is that does not feature in our
forecast because it is not government
policy as of now
when last question that I think uh Lucy
Lucy haga market news the bank's
projections show unemployment rising to
6.5 percent in three years time does the
banks see this as more of a
normalization in unemployment levels or
is it of concern
and as far as unemployment goes do you
see the risks as being more screwed to
the upside or downside
well I I'm sure Brian don't want to come
on this I if you talk about the term
neutralize normalization
um
you can interpret that in a number of
ways it seems to me is that
normalization relative to history well I
don't think our job is not to normalize
relative to some point in the past
because that you know that's not the
context we face now now of course
another way of expressing this question
is to go to the concept of a neutral
rate or the concept of of our star as
it's often called and you know sort of
speaking myself you know I think there
are two parts to that story one is what
you might call the shorter run cyclical
element I would and then the other one
is the longer run structural element
which I sort of which I did make the
speech on earlier in the summer and with
some colleagues uh have published a
paper on it though I have to say they
did most of the work and I didn't but do
they get the credits and I get the I get
the blame
um on on the the longer and she's
entirely Fair uh on the longer run point
on the sort of more structural Point
what I would say and that's the
conclusion of the work that we did
publish is that you know the longer and
these are Global drivers they're not UK
specific and the more cyclical thing you
can talk in so much more in UK terms on
the longer run issues
what did I say uh
an academic is ringing calling yes
um on the longer endpoint I think you
know the point we did make in in that
paper in that speech was that the longer
run Global drivers are very slow moving
structural drivers particularly aging
population aging which is obviously a
global feature and it's hard to see that
those things have sort of have run their
courses it were at the moment and
particularly played through so the
conclusion we drew from that was that um
where we didn't see that as being a long
run uh you know change in in the in that
sort of content context of the neutral
rate or our star going upwards I think
the most cyclical element of course yes
I think you can see some upward movement
you know for reasons that sort of in the
sense underline what we've published
today do you want to happen no no I mean
on on unemployment what it's worth
there's also a natural rate estimate we
have of that
and uh six and a half very clearly above
that
and of course any Rises regrettable
whether you think it's coming from below
or coming from above that natural rate
but it's you know
the complement to a recession
this is what tends to happen
and we've discussed at length the
underlying causes of
that recession and that
um
downturn the risks I think both on on
all the rails side of the forecast I
think of a table correct me if I'm wrong
GDP and unemployment are balanced then
either skewed in One Direction
well thank you very much for coming
we're out of time thank you very much